- Wait, what would you,
since you've seen all
of them at least once,
what, 'cause I'm gonna tell you mine,
what's your favorite Nic Cage movie?
What's your favorite?
- I think the movie that I made,
and it's recent,
that I felt like I had entered the room
and I, everything worked,
everything was like lightning in a bottle.
It just flowed, it just happened,
with everybody I was working with.
- Yeah.
- It just, one or two takes,
we all were-
- Everything clicked?
- Everything clicked.
- Ah.
We were all on our game.
I would say it was "Pig."
- Yeah.
- That movie.
(audience applauds)
- I love that.
I'm always interested to see which one
kinda sticks with people.
- Yeah. That one stayed with me.
That one resonated.
- I think for me, it's just
because when you see things
it's like music and
movies at a certain time,
like for your brain,
like when you're like,
in like junior high
or like high school or whatever,
there's that certain time when everything,
I know every line,
I know every, you know, in
the songs or the movies,
it's like when you remember things?
- Yes.
- Or like phone numbers.
Remember when we memorized phone numbers?
(audience laughs)
I don't know anyone's number.
I don't know mine.
But I think it would be "The Rock."
I love, "The Rock" was like
- Oh, that was great. Yeah.
(audience applauding)
- I think 'cause when I was a kid,
I was obsessed with that movie.
Like I love that it taught
me historically speaking.
I didn't know what Alcatraz
was before I saw that movie.
And I went on a deep dive
on like, what that was
and who was there.
- Right.
- And I love when movies
introduce you to stuff like that
that you didn't know, like
historically speaking.
- Absolutely.
- I think that's really cool.
Also the "National
Treasures" do that for me.
(audience applauds)
Cause I was like, is that real or made up?
- Yeah, Yeah.
- I was like, I was like,
I love anything that like sends me
into like, Googling stuff.
(audience members chuckle)
- Sure.
- I think it's like, you know,
it was like thought-provoking.
- Yeah.
- And also at that age, I
just thought it was cool.
And I was like, how did he handle the,
and when you (laughs), one of the best,
I'm not gonna ruin the whole movie.
(audience laughs)
But one of the best (laughs)
this new movie is,
there's someone in the
movie that's an uber fan.
And there's this room full of like,
it's like, if you were,
if I were to walk in,
what if you were really
to walk into a room
where someone was that big of a fan?
- Yeah.
- Would you be nervous?
- No, I don't think so.
- No?
- I've had great
experiences meeting people.
- Okay.
- Most of the, 99.9% of the time.
- Not nervous that they
wanna wear your skin,
nervous that you're not gonna,
(audience laughs)
not that kind of nervous.
- Right.
- I don't ever feel that kind of nervous.
People are generally cool.
I mean nervous that you're
gonna let them down.
'Cause, they have you up on a pedestal.
- Oh that, yeah.
- Yeah!
- Well, I don't see
myself as on a pedestal
and I don't think about...
- I know, but they do!
(audience laughs)
- Right, well, that, and well,
the thing, the thing is like
I'm not thinking about it in those terms.
Like I can't get nervous
because I, I actually don't recall
when I wake up in the morning
that I'm in movies or that I,
people might know who I am.
- No, no, I'm like this too.
I get, I get it.
- Yeah.
- But sometimes I'm like,
"Oh, I hope I don't let you down."
Especially if they, they
like tattoo something.
- Oh that, yeah. That...
(audience laughs)
- And I'm like, oh my god,
I could seriously let you down.
And like, what are you gonna do?
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, that.
- Yeah.
- But I have to remind myself
that I'm actually somebody
that maybe might have inspired them
to get a tattoo of my face on their arm.
And I don't think of
myself in those terms.
- That's amazing.
- So it doesn't come up.
And then I'm sometimes confused
as to why are you acting that way with me?
(Kelly and audience laugh)
What is going on?
- What's wrong with you?
- What is wrong with me?
Did I do something?
- What are you on?
And can I have some?
(Kelly and audience laughing)
So I hear that you do this.
And I can't, I try not to
ever do anything like this,
because I feel like it'll affect me.
But do, you Google yourself, right?
- It's awful. It's absolutely awful.
(audience groaning with sympathy)
- Okay. But do you, why
do you Google yourself?
- Oh, gosh.
It's Google, I call it Google-itis.
And I think secretly
- Okay.
we all do it but no one wants to admit it,
but I mean the, the problem is...
- No, I literally don't because...
- Well, I believe you. But I mean...
- I literally don't 'cause I get worried.
'Cause I don't wanna know what
everybody's talking about.
- Well, exactly, I mean.
And that's the, that's
the part of it that hurts.
But because it does, there are...
- Because I'll find out in interviews.
- Well, I, that happens to me, too.
But what, what it is is
that I sometimes wanna,
it was my New Year's resolution
not to Google myself.
And then, by accident,
by habit, by autopilot,
I went, (mumbles), oh no!
And I dropped the phone.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah.
- So it's, it doesn't,
it's hard to not Google oneself.
The reason why I do it
is because sometimes
you get ahead of a story before,
like an untruth,
- Yes.
and you can call someone
and say...
- The rumor mill.
You can say, you shut this down now.
- Yeah.
- That's the only reason why I do it.
But I'm looking forward to just putting
the phone on silent and not doing it.
And I have to train myself.
- You know what?
You should see, is there's this thing
called "Social Dilemma."
It's like a documentary.
- Oh, it's great.
- Oh my god.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know, you don't wanna be this guy.
- Yeah. That was scary.
That was scary, yeah.
- Yeah. I literally deleted
like everything from my phone. (laughs)
- Well the, the thing is,
Google actually came to me
and said we want you to advertise for us.
And I, I try not to
do commercials.
- Yeah.
- I, I don't do commercials.
- I did one a million years ago in Japan.
And then I got burned
because I thought I was promoting
a toy called Pachinko,
'cause my cousin Roman
had a Pachinko machine
when we were growing up and I'd play.
And I thought it was fun.
And it turned out to be Japanese gambling.
So I said, I'm never
doing another commercial.
(audience laughs)
- Oh.
- So that was why I got burned.
But what was the story
I was gonna tell you about the commercial?
(snaps)
Google wanted me to do something
and then I saw the movie
you just mentioned,
"The Social Dilemma."
- Yes. "The Social Dilemma."
- And I said, I don't want to touch this.
- I know, it scared me.
- Yeah. It's very scary.
- So I like took it all away.
- 'Cause at the end
they're like robots, right?
- This guy.
- Yeah. That was the one that got me.
- And they all know
they're they're watching.
(Nic and audience laugh)
- They're listening.
- The algorithm knows
what you want
- Yes.
and they will sell it to you.
- Yeah.
- They know I love sugar. Um, anyway.
(audience laughs)
So we Googled you before the show
'cause we wanted to know what came up.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
So this is, this is literally
what it says.
- Oh, yes!
- That you have a crush on
Miss Piggy, is this true?
- It's true. It's true.
(audience laughs)
- I love that this,
if this were what was said
about me, I would Google.
- She, well, I...
- See, this is fun when
you Google yourself.
I'm talking about, they're like mean.
- Yeah.
- So, yeah.
Or they get in your life,
like in a weird way.
- Yeah.
- So that's why I don't.
- Yeah, there you see.
But, she, Miss Piggy is adorable.
I love her.
- She's adorable.
- Yeah.
- I love her.
I love, do you really love,
did you grow up with The Muppets?
You love The Muppets?
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I love those movies, so much fun.
- Yeah. I know.
- Jim Henson and uh...
- Fun and kind of scary sometimes.
- Very scary.
I love the one, that Charles...
- Depending on the film.
- Charles Grodin was in one.
He was terrific.
- Yeah. Didn't Jim Henson
do "The Labyrinth?"
- "The Labyrinth" was great.
- Yeah.
With Bowie, right?
- That, yeah.
- Terrific.
- And I loved it, but Hoggle,
all those little dudes,
they, they were scary.
(audience laughs)
- They were, they were really scary.
- Yeah. And that child was abducted.
- Yeah.
- If you think about it,
it's a crazy story.
(audience laughs)
- It's very scary.
- Yeah.
One of my favorite films of all time.
- It's beautiful.
- I love it from childhood,
but I'm like, that's messed up.
- Kind of like a
nightmare, but what he did,
(Kelly softly screams)
what Henson did with those creatures,
those puppets-
- Yeah.
- was a different look
entirely from the Muppets.
- It did, like, change my whole thought
on like what I
- That's right.
should wish for.
- 'Cause like,
- Yeah.
- maybe that will come true.
- But, Bowie was fun on that, wasn't he?
- Oh my god, I loved it.
- Yeah. And wasn't it
Jennifer Connolly? She's so-
- Jennifer Connolly, I
think it was her first film.
- So good in that.
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
That was a great film.
I love it.
The babe with the power.
I love all the songs.
(audience cheering)